but I got a bit of a different kind of
video for you today not sure what it's
going to do for views but I want to talk
about it and that ain't nothing but
first let you know this portion of the
video is brought to you by Pluto TV
Pluto TV is a free video streaming
service that has hundreds of live
channels and thousands of movies and TV
shows on demand that are updated
frequently everything from comedies
action thriller drama True Crime game
shows have the prices right with
legendary host Bob Barker I watched that
show all the time they also have CSI
Miami that you can binge so anytime I
make a joke a pun and then go on my
channel you can get the reference so
click the link below download the free
Pluto TV apps accessible on your smart
TV smartphone Tablet any web browser
once again this portion of the video is
brought to you by Pluto TV and now I'm
just talking about Star Trek the Next
Generation which first bit of a
disclaimer this is five of my favorite
episodes of Star Trek the Next
Generation not necessarily the top five
episodes because in making top five
episodes I can think of 20 episodes I'd
want to be there the kind of mental
gymnastics it takes to whittle that down
to the top five is probably why I've
never done a Star Trek the Next
Generation video never done a video on
one of my favorite shows of all time a
couple of these episodes I think are in
the echelon of top five greatest of all
time but I digress these are just five
of my favorites which starting out this
list we're going to start out light by
light I mean it's an episodic episode
called cause and effect the premise is
really simple and actually starts out
like what the what did I just watch the
Enterprise explodes everyone dies and
then they're all playing poker and
everything seems fine long story short
the Enterprise is in a Time Loop they're
reliving the same day over and over
again same day for them it's essentially
10 minutes or so for us unlike Bill
Murray and Groundhog Day they're not
aware of it say for this sense of deja
vu that they kind of have maybe I really
like this episode because I like it when
things explain deja vu but I think
there's something profoundly talented
about showing the same 10 minutes or so
of a show over and over again and not
having it feel redundant the crew starts
remembering more and more as time goes
on Beverly Crusher moves the glass to
another location so she doesn't tip the
glass over because she knows she's going
to then she ends up tipping it over
anyway showing constants and variables
it's one of these episodes in my yearly
or so next Generation binge when it gets
to cause and effect I'm always like oh
sweet just an enjoyable hour of
Television my one thing is at the end of
the episode they find out they were
stuck in this Loop for about two weeks
or so I think it would have been kind of
Epic if they were stuck for about a
hundred years maybe one year but you
know more than two weeks but it is what
it is it doesn't matter it could be two
weeks could be a thousand years point is
they were in it and then they get out of
it I wanted one episode in here that's
just like
enjoyable one hour locked in the entire
time never bored time Paradox now these
next four episodes I didn't notice when
I made the list but when I was going
through the list prepping to do a video
on it
um they're all Picard Centric episodes
which again unintentional I guess just
kind of shows how great the character of
Jean-Luc Picard is but we're gonna start
out heavy with a two-part or chain of
command in this two-parter Jean-Luc
Picard is part of an away Mission with
Beverly Crusher and Lieutenant Commander
Wharf and then Picard gets captured by
the Kardashians every two-parter has
that question of like well what's best
what's the best part of this two-parter
the first part or the second part with
chain of command as much as I love the
captain Jellico Dynamic with Commander
Riker part two is the money it's the
dynamic between Sir Patrick Stewart and
the late great David Warner these two
going head-to-head Toe to Toe and Picard
being tortured for an entire hour
is just it's electrifying to watch it's
such a simple thing that the cardassian
wants Picard to do he just wants them to
say there are five lights when in fact
there are only four that's it just a
battle of wills and that heartbreaking
ending that sit down the Picard has with
councilor Troy next generation is great
about having that last bit of dialogue
that really hammers home the point or
last scene of some sort where he talks
about he swore he could see Five Lights
but that shows that
thinking of how to phrase it because I
don't want to say he broke his mind but
he definitely affected Picard's Minds
for him to see five lights but he never
broke his spirit
that's why he's Picard next up we have
an episode that when I was a kid was
always in the top five greatest episodes
conversation any marathon because as the
seasons were going on they would always
have these marathons of Star Trek and
the inner light was always part of it
and I was always like come on we're the
Borg bring on the Borg but then I got
older and I was like oh wow this is this
is one of the only episodes it might
actually be the only Next Generation
episode that brings me to the brink of
Tears in the Inner Light the Enterprise
comes across this probe that zaps Picard
the Picard just wakes up in this other
place this other planet no one knows
what the Enterprise is they don't know
what he's talking about he doesn't know
what to make of the situation it's quite
clever to take a reprieve from Picard's
experience on the planet and then go to
the bridge for a couple minutes in those
couple minutes or years you know that
years are going by for this experience
that Picard's having and in the course
of these years he starts accepting his
place on this planet he starts thinking
maybe the Enterprise was all BS maybe it
was a big fever hallucination I had at
one point he learns how to play the
flute you notice how at first he's
playing songs that he knows from Earth
you know the Ferreira Jacques after he
was playing Picard music then at a point
you're like that is not Earth music
that's that's music of this world he's
kind of resigned himself to this life
and it is a good life you know he has
his wife who loves him he has kids he
has grandkids he lives this entire life
that Jean-Luc Picard himself would never
get to experience without this probe
zapping him he experiences the joy that
this life has to offer the pain that
this life has to offer then he wakes up
back on the bridge of the Enterprise and
the whole ordeal was about 25 minutes
long in 25 minutes Picard lives an
entire lifetime and for me the most
important moment is that end moment when
Riker's like well the probe shut down
but we found this inside and it's his
flute that he had on the world you know
when he was living that life I mean the
episode clearly sticks with the concept
that this was a lifetime of memories a
life that he lived in 25 minutes but if
he didn't play the flute at the end it
being a crazy Star Trek scenario the
audience might have that leeway to be
like okay so is it gonna start fading
from his memory I imagine it's going to
start fading from his memory possibly
him playing the flute at the end of the
episode cuts that concept cold there's
no wiggle room to make that argument
that was just a lifetime of memories and
he will have them forever and in every
episode past the Inner Light where he
plays his flute I'm always loved that
feeling of
that was a lifetime of memories
he still thinks about his kids
that aren't around it's an incredible
episode a very thought-provoking episode
I enjoy the fact that I just get
something new out of it every time I
watch it and I get more out of it the
older I get next up is the episode
tapestry I'm not gonna lie an episode
with John Delancey as Q had to be on
this list somewhere added bonus is one
of my favorite episodes of next
generation of all time episode starts
out Picard's been shot in the chest he
has an artificial heart so he dies and
he gets to heaven and Q is God the
reason Picard died is because he had
that artificial heart he got that
artificial heart because when he was a
really Brash young Cadet he picked a
fight with a group of Nas against at the
domjot table got stabbed right through
the heart so he was like if you could do
it again and cargos things would be
different he was giving him the
opportunity to undo that mistake of his
past so he will not die here's the thing
though he undoes it he avoids the fight
at the domjot table he's back on the
Enterprise as Junior trade officer
nobody this is a very powerful and
Timeless lesson of life not only that
but it's also one of those moments that
I realized okay so Q is not just a troll
he actually likes Picard and he wants to
help him this is a moment where clearly
Q is teaching Picard a very valuable
lesson and that lesson is you might have
these moments in your past that you're
ashamed of these moments that you cringe
when you think about as much as people
tend to reflect on the good of the past
the good and the bad the successes and
the mistakes they all exist and they all
exist with purpose you can't undo them
you pull at these unsightly threads and
unravel the tapestry of your life it's a
great episode not only is it absurdly
entertaining just in its premise and its
execution Sir Patrick Stewart and John
Delancey they're incredible together I
suppose I didn't expect it either I
would expect the young Brash Cadet
backstory to be given to Riker giving it
to Picard completely unexpected it's
amazing seeing this Great Captain and
the flawed path that he came from makes
him so much more real so much more human
it's one of the best episodes and we're
killing it off with the last one on this
list the end of the list that would be
best of both worlds another two part of
this was the season finale of season
three rolling over to the season
premiere of season four in season two Q
introduced the Enterprise to the Borg
and at that point it was known well the
Borg know about us now so they're going
to be coming for us all this time later
season finale of three they engaged the
Borg and the Borg do what I don't think
anyone expected I was a kid when this
episode came out and it rocked my world
I remember being like
this this isn't this doesn't happen the
Borg capture Jean-Luc Picard and they
assimilate him into the collective as
lucutus aboard and this is a situation
that forever stayed with Jean-Luc Picard
it was also the moment that Picard
became he went from the captain of the
Enterprise's Untouchable person
to someone who could be hurt to this
degree and it ends with one of the
biggest Cliffhanger moments of all time
Mr Wolf
fire
bye see you after the summer what I had
to wait a whole summer to find out what
happened this dude
I didn't know I didn't know what I was
going to do whereas with chain of
command which is funny both of those two
partners do put Jean-Luc Picard in a
very vulnerable situation and hurt him
to an extreme degree but with chain of
command I feel part two is the strong
part like that's what I think of when I
think of what I love about that
two-parter with Best of Both Worlds it
is part one it's that reveal when Picard
turns and looks and you see that he's
been assimilated into the collective an
olive Trek this is one of the prominent
moments it's like it you ever get the
feeling that you're in an alternate
reality like you just thinking you're
like we're in the worst timeline for the
people in the world of Star Trek the
Next Generation this was the moment
where they would forever feel like that
Jean-Luc Picard as lacute is destroying
a myriad of Starfleet vessels is what
springboard's Deep Space Nine but it is
extremely heartbreaking in part two when
you know Picard comes back and he has
all the Borg implants and he's talking
and they said what you remember how much
do you remember and he goes
everything he just remembers everything
he remembers all the killing that he did
and all the death and all the people and
the ships that he destroyed he'll never
forget it he carries it through the
entire series that's why in Star Trek
first Contact the movie he's Captain
Ahab as Lily tells him it's like oh Ahab
has to go to hunt his whale and he does
he just wants to hurt the Borg because
they hurt him this two-parter brought a
vulnerability to Jean-Luc Picard that
never quit it's always there's there
from then to the end alright so that's
my list of five of my favorite Star Trek
episodes kind of a cheat because in
these episodes there are two parters so
it's essentially seven episodes so
whatever it is what it is Star Trek the
Next Generation is I think one of the
greatest shows ever made it remains a
yearly binge I mean it's not exactly a
year but every year or so I'll just
re-binge the series and One Thing
Remains there's a constant and that is I
will get more
out of that binge
than I thought I could you know like at
a point you think oh I know what the
show is and it was about I know what
these episodes are about I know what
they're going to give me and somehow
these episodes just give more so I ask
you Star Trek the Next Generation what
are five of your favorite episodes
there's so many I didn't even talk about
frame of mind Elementary my dear data
shipping a bottle iborg measure of them
okay I could keep going well depending
on how much you guys like this video
maybe I'll do a part two and that's
there you go but what are five episodes
that you love whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
yeah oh fortnight